معنا الان محمد البقالي جاهز من امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي بهولندا
مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي مرحبا بك اذا
ما الذي ننتظره اليوم وقد اعلن ان المحكمه
ستنظر بعد الاستماع الى الطرفين مقدم
الدعوه
واسرائيل التي ترد على هذه الدعوه ستنظر
في طلب التدابير
المؤقته بالفعل محمد المحكمه الان سمعت
الى الطرفين القضاه سينسحبون
للمداولة هنا والان وبالتالي فعلى المحكمه
ان تتخذ قرارا مستعجلا يتوقع خلال نهايه
الشهر او خلال اسابيع قليله على كل حال ما
سمعناه اليوم من الوفد القانوني او الفريق
القانوني
الاسرائيلي يحدد لنا طبيعه المخاوف
الاسرائيليه المتعلقه بما يتوقع ان يصدر
من المحكمه المخاوف الاسرائيليه الكبيره
تتعلق اساسا بهذه التدابير المؤقته التي
يمكن ان تصدر المحكمه لماذا لان المحكمه
يمكن ان تصدر قرارا تامر فيه اسرائيل بوقف
عملياتها العسكريه لانها تنطوي على خطر
الاباده كما هي معرفه قانونيا وفقا
لاتفاقيه منع الاباده الموقعه عام
1948 اذا صدر هذا القرار فهذا يعني ان
اسرائيل قانونيا وفق القانون الدولي يجب
ان تكون ان تلتزم به والا ستصبح من وجهه
النظر القانون الدولي دوله مارقه لا تلتزم
بقرارات اعلى هيئه قضائيه دوليه وربما ما
هو اسوا بالنسبه لاسرائيل هو ان تهمه
الاباده لحظتها ستتحول من مجرد اتهام ربما
ينظر اليه على انه مرسل الى اتهام قضائي
او ادانه قضائيه تصدر عن
هيئه امميه هي محكمه العدله الدوليه وهي
اعلى هيئه قضائيه ناهيك على ان هذا الامر
سيفتح الباب بالنسبه للذين رفعوا دعاوى
امام محكمه الجنايات الدوليه وهنا يجب ان
نميز بين محكمه العدل الدوليه ومحكمه
الجنايات الدوليه كلاهما في لهاي محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه على بعد كيلومترات قليله
من هنا و لكن محكمه العدل الدوليه تحكم
بين الدول وهي تشبه على مستوى الداخلي
القضاء المدني فهي لا تصدر مقررات
الاعتقال او مذكرات الحبس خلافا لمحكمه
الجنايات الدوليه التي مهمتها هي معاقبه
الافراد الذين يرتكبون جرائم ضد الانسانيه
وفي هذه الحاله فان صدور قرار من محكمه
العدل
الدوليه يقضي او يامر اسرائيل بان توقف
اعمالها سيساعد الجهات القانونيه التي
تقدمت بدعوه الى محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
ومن بينهم محامون من بينهم ايضا منظمه
مراسلون بلا حدود فيما يتعلق بمقتل
الصحفيين من بينهم دول اخرى من بينها جنوب
افريقيا ايضا رفعت دعوه امام محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه وبالتالي فهذا الحكم
الذي اذا صدر عن هذه المحكمه سيكون دافعا
للجهات التي رفعت دعاوه امام محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه ثم سيكون ضاغطا على
المدعي العام لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
كريم خان الذي يتهمه كثير من الحقوقيين
ومن المدافعين عن حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
بانه يتلك وانه ربما يقع تحت ضغوط دول
كبرى تحول دون ان يقوم باجراءات التحقيق
كما يجب كما صارع لذلك عندما تعلق الامر
على سبيل المثال في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
يمكن ان نفهم التحديات التي تواجهها
اسرائيل او القلق الذي تشعر به بشان
القرار الذي يمكن ان يصدر من جهه هناك
القرارات الوقائيه والاحتراز التي يفترض
ان تصدر سريعا وقد توجه امرا لاسرائيل
بوقف عمليات العمليات القتاليه او في الحد
الادنى ان تسمح بايصال المساعدات وان
تمتنع عن قصف المستشفيات والاماكن المدنيه
وغير ذلك ثم بعد ذلك ستنظر المحكمه في
مفهوم الاباده ك في عمق الدعوه وهذا الامر
سيتطلب سنوات اسرائيل ربما الان اولويتها
ليست مساله الاباده التي ستتطلب سنوات لان
هذا
امر كما يقال امر لاحق وسيحدث بعد سنوات
ولا يعرف كيف ستكون الظروف والسياقات لكن
ما يعنيها اساسا هي هذه الاجراءات
الاحترازيه او ما يعنيها اولا هي هذه
الاجراءات الاحترازيه لذلك لاحظنا ان كان
هناك تركيز كبير من الفريق القانوني على
محاوله اقناع المحكمه بان لا تتخذ هذا
القرار من خلال اولا التركيز على ان
اسرائيل انما تقوم بحرب تقول انها تدافع
فيه تدافع فيها عن نفسها وانها لم تبدا
بهذه الحرب وان نيه الاباده غير متوفره
لانه من
شروط توفر او اركان جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه توفر النيه ولاحظنا انه كان هناك
تركيز كبير من الفريق القانوني الاسرائيلي
على التاكيد على غياب هذه النيه من خلال
الحديث على المسارات الممرات الانسانيه من
خلال الحديث عن المساعدات من خلال الحديث
عن تاخير العمليه البريه لمده اسابيع الى
اخره ولكن من الواضح من الواضح ان ما
قدمته اسرائيل في الحقيقه على مستوى
المرافعه كان ضعيفا وفقا لما سمعناه من
القانوني ليس لان فريق الفريق القانوني
الاسرائيلي ضعيف الفريق القانوني
الاسرائيلي معروف على المستوى القانوني
الدولي خبراء مشهود لهم بالخبره في
القانون الدولي ولكن لان الموقف
الاسرائيلي نفسه او الموقف الاسرائيلي
نفسه هو ضعيف جدا امام الصور امام الادله
وامام ما ما يحدث بالفعل في غزه كان هناك
على سبيل المثال حديث من الفريق القانوني
على
ان القضاء في حال ارتكب الجنود مخالفات
فان القضاء الاسرائيلي هو الذي سيحاكم وهو
مستعد للقيام بما يجب في هذا الاتجاه ولكن
هذا الامر الموقف الاسرائيلي ضعيف فيه
بالنظر الى ان هناك ازمه على مستوى القضاء
في اسرائيل يعرفها الجميع من خلال محاوله
السياسيين ووضع يدهم على القضاء وهذا يضعف
من جديد الموقف الاسرائيلي على مستوى
المحكمه على كل حال المحكمه هي التي ستفصل
الاصل لكن هل فعليا محمد المحكمه
ستنظر في في هذه النقطه بشمول المشهد
بشموليته ام ان من مهام المحكمه ان تنظر
في الورق مقابل الورق في الدعوه مقابل
الرد دون النظر لان الحكم من المفترض ان
يصدر قريبا دون النظر في في في الخلفيات
والسياقات حتى
التاريخيه
للاحداث القضاه بشكل عام هنا في المحكمه ي
رض ان يحكموا وفق اطار قانوني هو اتفاقيه
منع الاباده الجماعيه بمعنى لديهم ادله
ووثائق قدمت من جنوب افريقيا لديهم دفعات
قدمت من اسرائيل سيقررون ما اذا كانت هذا
الذي او المعارك والهجمات التي تنفذها
اسرائيل والحرب منذ ثلاث اشهر تقريبا
ينطبق عليها هذا الوصف ام لا لكن بالتاكيد
هؤلاء قضاه ليسوا منفصلين عن الواقع بشكل
كامل هم لديهم خ خبره قانونيه ولكن لديهم
خبره ايضا على المستوى التاريخي على
المستوى ولديهم ايضا
تفضيلاتهم هذا الامر لا يجب ان ننكره
لديهم ايضا
انتماءاتهم بالنسبه للبلدان لكن وفق ما
سمعنا على الاقل من القضاه ومن قاض هنا
داخل المحكمه قال ان القضاه حريصون كل
الحرص على ان يسكتوا تفضيلاتهم الداخليه
والخاصه سواء تعلقت بانتماء تهم الجغرافيه
والثنيه او بمواقفهم الخاصه ولكن الموقف
التاريخي والقراءه التاريخيه للصراع اتوقع
ان القضاه بالتاكيد يستحضرون وفقا لقراءته
ولكن ما هو مطلوب من المحكمه الان هو ان
تقدم قراءه هل او تقدم جوابا على هذا
السؤال هل ما تقوم به اسرائيل الان يندرج
ضمن حرب الاباده ام لا هذا هو الجواب الذي
ستجيب عنه ولكن يجب ان اشير هنا الى مساله
غايه في الاهميه المحكمه لن تجيب على هذا
السؤال بمطلقه بل ستجيب فقط على ما اذا
كانت تعتقد بان ما يحدث يخشى ان يؤدي الى
جرائم اباده وبالتالي يجب منعه والا
فالنظر في جوهر الموضوع هذا سيتطلب سنوات
وبشكل عام المحكمه عندما تنظر في التدابير
الوقائيه او التدابير
الاحترازيه الشروط التي تطلبها وتفترض
تكون اقل من الحكم في الجوه
التجارب السابقه او الخلفيه التاريخيه
تقول ان المحكمه خلال السنوات الثلاثه
الماضيه في حكمين ضد نيمار مع الشعب
الروهينجا وضد روسيا في مواجهه اوكرانيا
حكمت باحكام احترازيه وقائيه امرت فيها
البلدين بوقف حربهما
ضد ضد كل طرف على كل حال الروهينجا ضد
نيمار ضد الروهينجا وروسيا ضد اوكرانيا
امرته بوقف هذه الحرب على اعتبار انها
تندرج ضمن الاباده الانسانيه وهذا ما يرجح
ان المحكمه قد تذهب في نفس الاتجاه ودعني
هنا محمد اقول شيئا ربما جمله مختصره
اسرائيل بغض النظر عن الحكم الذي سيصدر عن
المحكمه يبدو انها قد خسرت الكثير قبل ان
تصدر هذه المحكمه وهؤلاء الذين يقفون هنا
وهم من الشباب سواء من الشباب من العرب
الذين ولدوا هنا وكثير منهم من الجيل من
الغربيين الذين لم يكونوا لديهم فكره
واضحه عن القضيه الفلسطينيه واستعادوا
وعيهم بهذه القضيه خلال الثلاثه اشهر
الماضيه والذين جاؤوا هنا وهو ما تؤكده
استطلاعات الراي ان الجيل الجديد في الغرب
بشكل عام هو لا يثق كثيرا في الروايه
الاسرائيليه ناهيك عن خساره اسرائيل حربها
الاخلاقيه لانها تقدم نفسها على انها
لديها الجيش الاكثر اخلاقيه في العالم
تتحدث عن جيش الدفاع تقول بانها تتخذ كل
الاجراءات من اجل حمايه المدنيين مجرد وضع
اسرائيل في المحكمه في قفص الاتهام
ومساءلتها بهذه التهمه تهمه الاباده
الجماعيه وهي تهمه على المستوى الدولي
شنيعه جدا قليله هي الجيوش التي حكمت
بتهمه مثل هذه والاكثر من ذلك انها وضعت
في المحكمه التي اسست عقب المحرك والتي
اعتبرت بالنسبه لاسرائيل لحظتها نصرا فهي
تحاكم في نفس المحكمه هذا يعني ان اسرائيل
قد خسرت بالفعل الكثير بغض النظر عن الحكم
الذي سي متابع معك محمد البقالي انت من
امام هذه المحكمه الان